libéré la parole pour échanger les
expériences mais surtout pour partager
ses souffrances
le café des aidants est un moment où
chacun peut parler de son quotidien
c'est là sous le kiosque de la case
grand air que la parole se libère d'un
échange entre nous un donc ça reste un
petit peu confidentiel voilà et ensuite
on est là pour parler un petit peu
librement les uns et des autres de la
situation des dents donc sur le thème
d'aujourd'hui qui est comment faire face
à l'évolution de leurs proches raconter
ses souffrances et partager celle des
autres
liane et daniel viennent ici en couple
ils cèdent chacun leur manière
tous les choix l'homme je pouvais pas
discuter raconter mon histoire comment
ça s'est passé mais je ne pouvais pas
j'étais toujours en larmes je ne pouvais
rien dire nous apporte quand même un
certain bien-être à la fois sur dix on
sur un plan physique et psychologique
aussi mais ce parce que quand on en
ressort là on a un petit peu plus de
tenue soit se dit bon on a discuté
ensemble vous savez on a tous les mêmes
problèmes malheureusement c'est ça le
café des aidants un espace offert par le
gie ps ap maison de l'aide à la personne
aux aidants un temps d'échangé de
rencontre pour se trouver des solutions
de professionnels encadrent les
interventions un travailleur social et
une psychologue
on va essayer on va essayer de voir du
côté de l'association là si vous y avez
droit et comment éventuellement
démissionnez trouve à vous parler d'eux
de tout ce que ça peut provoquer comme
comme angoisse comme irritation comme
fatigue
bon on est retombé sur la les solutions
de répit de repos et du type père grand
père aussi pour pour essayer de se
reconstruire un petit peu reprendre
reprendre un peu du poil de la bête ces
importantes d'abord parce que justement
c'est une coupure ça leur permet de
sortir un petit peu de leur enfermement
on a aussi entendu parler de prison je
suis en prison soit entre quatre murs
chez moi donc d'abord un ca faire la
coupure se rendent compte effectivement
se rendre compte de leur rôle et que
leur rôle d'aidant ça n'est pas rien
c'est quelque chose de très lourd que
même en général les autres membres de la
famille ne se rendent pas compte à quel
point c'est lourd et ensuite ce sont
aussi des personnes qui peuvent arriver
un état d'épuisement physique mais aussi
psychique surtout psychique et là on est
là nous pour les aider justement à
prendre conscience de l'état dans lequel
elles sont pas ce qu'elles se rendent
pas toujours compte et les remonter
ensuite petit à petit vers quelque chose
de plus énergique
le café des aidants on permet à ces
personnes qui partagent la souffrance de
leurs proches de comprendre qu'elles ne
sont pas seules que des solutions
existent rencontrer des gens changer de
cadre pouvoir avoir ce lieu là pour
échanger avec des personnes qui vivent
la même chose que vous et qui est qui et
d'un comment dire qui a avancé dans ce
processus de la souffrance de
l'acceptation on introduit un thème et
suite à ce thème
on lance un débat sur par exemple la
qualité de la relation avec les dés ou
bien comment faire face à la maladie de
son proche et si vous voulez donc que ça
permet aux personnes de d'échanger les
personnes qui sont là ils ont tous vécu
des choses et ils apportent leur
expérience par rapport aux sujets ou ski
ce qu'elles vivent tous les jours et
avec l'aide de la psychologue qui est là
aussi bien pour gérer un petit peu et
toutes ces émotions qui peuvent surgir
dans ce groupe où des questions très
techniques que le travailleur social
peut répondre ou peut faire des
orientations et ceux qui viennent la
première fois le coeur rempli de
souffrance peuvent s'appuyer sur
l'expérience de ceux qui sont passés par
ce même chemin
première séance c'était je me vois ma
place là je pouvais pas parler pas parlé
je regardais comme ça on posait des
questions et au fur et à mesure j'ai su
comment dire sauter le pas et de
d'arriver à la à ce stade là puis posé
trouvé de solution parce que sinon on
est trop tout seul on ne sait pas on
sait pas comment faire on ne sait pas
comment se débrouiller est vraiment là
c'est vraiment une journée vraiment bien
j'ai bien apprécié vous rencontrer voilà
deux personnes comme un peu comme nous
voilà pour vraiment très bien
tu peux à super les arts offert aux
aînés ces deux journées de repos et de
votre chose est de sortir d'une hauteur
de tous nos problèmes qu'ils rencontrent
au quotidien à quoi le café des aidants
véritable sas de décompression où les
change devient vitale une parole qui
continue bien après que leur se soit
écoulée et des conversations qui se
poursuivre entre les aidants qui
s'échangent leurs numéros de téléphone
par les être écoutés être aidé tout ceci
autour d'un café
celui de l'amitié de la solidarité le
café des aidants
ça se déroule deux fois dans la semaine
sur les journées c'est le mercredi et le
jeudi
donc là le café des aidants donc c'est
le la baisse 1 on est labellisé avec
l'association française des aidants une
décentralisation du café des aidants
mais y en a deux ici et un à saint denis
ça se déroule de pareilles c'est un
rendez vous mensuel à l'espace réglé
au niveau du bas de la rivière on a un
planning pareil je pense que c'est tous
les mercredis on à partir de 14h jusqu'à
16h que notre collègue donc du conseil
général et moi-même animons ce qu'a fait
au bas de la rivière